Okay, now for a quick quiz.
We have this definition of decorator, and we've seen how that works.
Here's an alternative that was proposed by Darius Bacon,
which is this1 line--return the function that updates wrapper for the decorator
applied to the function from the original function,
and then 1 more line, which says, decorator = decorator of decorator.
Can you get any more recursive than that?
The question is, does this work?
I want you to give me the best answer.
The possible answers are yes, it does; no, it's an error; no, it correctly updates decorator
such as n_ary, but not the decorated function such as (seq);
or no, my brain hurts.